Maybe me more than
I picked it.
Um,
I was conditioned that an early age to
appreciate nature photography through my
grandfather who's a,
he was Irish and,
um,
he left Ireland in the 1920s and moved
to India and then the,
he was a doctor and,
um,
and in the early part of his life,
he was engaged in safaris and whatnot,
which is not that glorious,
uh,
looking back in retrospect because he
shot tigers and whatnot.
But in the twenties and thirties,
you know,
I suppose it had a different type of a
social imprint as we might examine
today.
But in his midlife,
he traded has a,
is gone for a camera.
And so I continued doing his safaris and
expeditions both in India and then later
on in,
in Africa and Botswana and Tanzania and
Namibia and,
uh,
and settled.
He lived in,
um,
in Swaziland,
just a north or South Africa.
So his,
um,
his body of,
uh,
photography work was,
um,
uh,
impressed upon me at an early age
through a slideshows.
And I sat through many slideshows are
watching elephants and giraffes and
whatnot.
So that was my sort of early affinity
to,
uh,
to landscape photography.
And I started taking pictures in South
Africa myself when I was about 12,
um,
on,
you know,
in Safaris and,
and whatnot.
And,
uh,
and then it just progressed.
And I always somehow was picked to,
uh,
to shoot.
And,
um,
and I translated that into a career in
advertising where I did a lot of
directing,
actually all of commercials and music
videos.
And then,
um,
I decided to focus more specifically on
photography and get out of,
of advertising.
I wasn't entirely comfortable,
uh,
eventually,
as I developed as an advocate,
uh,
with promoting messages of consumerism.
So I,
uh,
I settled on portrait photography for,
um,
a career earning,
uh,
potential.
And then,
um,
and then of course,
I followed with my,
uh,
my advocacy
American landscape.
[inaudible].